i'm lee goldman Dean of the medical
school here at Columbia I decide to
write too much of a good thing because I
so frequently get asked questions by
friends and even family members why is
it so hard to lose weight do I really
take my blood pressure medicines should
I take an aspirin every day as I thought
about the answers to those questions I
realized that many of them linked back
directly to our genes our DNA who we are
and the difficulty in the modern world
of living with genes that by and large
were designed for tens of thousands of
years ago so there are four main
examples we use in the book one is
hunger the ability to gorge when food is
plentiful and the ability to store that
excess food and calories is fat that
protected our ancestors against an
uncertain future when food might not be
readily available second is our desire
for salt we crave salt because we needed
to avoid dehydration that was especially
important back in the Paleolithic era
when our main survival advantage was our
endurance arguably to run farther than
other animals so we're the best animal
in the entire world at running long
distances at having endurance
unfortunately on the same salt that is
critical for replacing the salt we
losing our sweat explains why about a
third of Americans have high blood
pressure third protective set of traits
are anxiety and the ability to withdraw
when we lose a battle our ancestors had
to be anxious vigilant to be sure they
didn't fall off a cliff or get stung by
a spider or killed by a woolly mammoth
in today's America more people die of
suicide and of all murder and well put
together even if from handguns guns in
America are responsible for more
suicides than murder that's because
those traits anxiety withdrawal which
can lead to
are no longer as protective as they used
to be and finally the book talks about
our ability to clot blood has to clot so
if we get injured we don't bleed to
death well clotting is a very important
protective mechanism but now far more
Americans die from heart attacks caused
by clots and the coronary arteries and
strokes caused by clots and the arteries
to our brain then die from any cause of
bleeding so each of these four traits
used to be protective still has some
protection but now about half of
American deaths are directly related to
these overprotective traits our genes
can possibly change as fast as we've
changed the world that just simply can't
happen especially because the conditions
that our genes are causing typically
occur well after we've had children and
even after they've had children so the
natural selection process can't work
simply can't there's a lot of hope and
oftentimes hype that we can change our
behaviors a lot of Public Health now
focuses on behavior change well I'm not
against behavior change but if behavior
change worked I wouldn't written this
book we're going to have to rely and I
argued to a greater rather than lesser
extent as time goes forward on
scientific advances that can help us and
increasingly we're going to look into
medications that can help people lose
weight we look to medications to help
people who have severe anxiety and
depression and for some people that
aspirin a day really does make sense so
it's not a self-help book what it does
hopefully talk about a roadmap that we
collectively can follow
you